[Music]
kyle is with us in montgomery alabama
hey kyle welcome to the ramsey show
hey there dave hey ken thanks for taking
my call today sure what's up
well my wife and i found the baby steps
about four years ago and we were
fortunate enough to start on baby step
three uh since then we've taught fpu two
times
but we we are still hesitant to uh cut
up the credit cards and close the
accounts we have that
fear of fraudulent debit card uh
purchases and i've heard you talk about
it before in the past about the
protections between debit and credit
cards yeah please please own research go
ahead
go ahead i'm sure my own research uh
following hearing those episodes i have
uh looked into it and found anecdotal
evidence that people suffer when their
debit cards get misused and then the
banks take a while or they may try to
refuse the refunds
by those
fraudulent charges do you have any
input or any other protections out there
that you would suggest to help prevent
those to help us get over that fear and
stop using credit cards yeah
um
first i would tell you that if you don't
get over the fear you should not lead
financial peace university
because it's you're telling you know
we're telling people to quit using
credit cards and you leading the class
are still using them as hypocritical
so that's not good for you it's not good
for the people in the class
so uh if you can't you get if you can't
deal with this issue i understand i'm
gonna be mad at you but it's
inconsistent for when the cornerstone of
the class is to get rid of all debt
so that you can become wealthy so let's
set that on the table first secondly
absolutely i understand yeah secondly i
carry
debit cards
um
and i have used them
literally all over the world i don't own
a single credit card
um
and i have had fraudulent transactions
i've had lots of scares lots of
shutdowns
lots of reverse charges
um i have never had a bank
uh hold money on me
and i'm i'm probably my point is i'm
probably more exposed to fraud than the
average person because i travel so much
and i do so many different kinds of
transactions and we run all of ramsey
solutions a 300 million dollar company
with debit cards the company doesn't
have any credit cards
and so you know i've got like several
hundred people that work on the team
that carry a ramsey
debit card so we've got
massive
exposure to what you're talking about
and our practical experience is it is so
rare
that something takes more than 24 or 48
hours to get refunded that it's uh you
know it's there now if you're buying
something
for
an amount of money
that if that amount of money doesn't get
returned to you
in 48 hours destroys your life
that says you shouldn't be buying
something like that
mathematically and so
there's another level of lack of wisdom
that's involved in some of those stories
that you find in the
deep dark recesses of the internet uh in
your uh research that you've done but
the the practical fact is
we see so little
misbehavior by banks or stress put on
people by this that it that the offset
of now we'll tell you this the people
that use credit cards and pay them off
every month 78
don't
pay them off every month so someone's
lying
about paying them off every month
because when you talk to people they all
say they pay them off every month and
nobody does
and so you know the number of people
that fall into the trap of
getting screwed over by the use of
credit cards versus fall into the trap
of having their life considerably offset
by a delayed refund in the rare event of
a fraudulent transaction that actually
does
cost you money and how long does it take
to get back in your account is uh
you know the the numbers don't even stay
i mean it's a bazillion times more on
credit cards the lives are destroyed and
messed up than they are by somebody not
getting a fraud refund on a debit card
and so the trade-off is not even close
uh yeah there is there is a reality that
that can happen and it does happen on
occasion but it is not a frequent thing
i'm giving you a set example
that that i literally have hundreds of
debit cards yeah i think the data will
show you kyle and i think you've done
enough research to know that the numbers
would tell you that it's an irritation
this fear that you have not a
devastation and there's two things you
could do you ask what could you do if
you don't have identity theft of zander
insurance stacey and i have that
everybody at ramsey solutions does
identity theft protection is going to
help you there and protect you and then
i will tell you i'm not going to endorse
any bank but our personal bank
they're so good with their security that
sometimes the state and i are out of
state and we forget to tell them we're
going something we just go to dinner and
it'll hit send me a text
your card was just charged your debit
card was charged at this restaurant are
you there are you in kaaba is it you yes
i am as a matter of fact it happened and
so um i i think you've created a boogie
man that really doesn't exist lurking
around every corner does it happen yes
is it is it devastating
number of times that the number of times
that it is an actual
serious financial problem to a family
versus the number of times a credit card
is an actual serious financial problem
credit card
one tenth of one percent these no they
don't even they don't even line up
they're not even close they're not in
the same stratosphere of the damage one
does versus the damage another does yeah
not even close and so the trade-off is
just not worth it on this one issue
because debit cards have a 100
fraud protection that's correct if it is
fraud the bank has to refund it that is
visas policy it is mastercard's policy
it is in there it's a zero liability
policy you can read it in their own
stuff
and so the people who say cr and he's
not saying this but the people that say
well credit cards have fraud protection
debit cards don't that's not true it's
just not true he's not saying that by
the way but um to his credit but the uh
but but
so for those of you out there your debit
card has the exact same fraud protection
your credit card has what he's referring
to is if you
uh went online and bought something with
your debit card and it was uh uh no if
someone someone someone stole your
identity and used your account or they
picked up your card number off a false
reader or something on a one of these
rip off atm machine things and they take
your card
and they go buy something with it and it
shows up in your account and it's 200
bucks the it does 200 does come out of
your account
out of your checking account
and then you report the fraud and the
bank has to put it back
and the number of times that that causes
disaster on a family is almost zero
because a banks put it back really
really fast and b you shouldn't be using
any financial transaction that if it
goes sideways destroys your life that's
correct
period now i'll tell you what does
happen and then people use this
to whine about this as a justification
rationalization for using their credit
cards and this is not kyle but i hear it
all the time for people that are man
keep my credit card and we keep one
opening said because when i travel they
put a hold
so when you check into a hotel all right
the one we were staying in the other
night i didn't use my car because we
were doing a corporate thing we're out
there and uh this account was set up
with omni but uh if i go check into an
omni or whatever by myself with sharon
and me they'll put a hold
on your account for the amount
so 400 bucks a night 300 bucks a night
200 whatever it is right they're gonna
put a hold on that and it might be a day
or two before it comes off but listen if
you can't afford a two or three or four
hundred dollar hold on your account
then you can't afford to stay in that
hotel you should be at home working
that's you know these are the things you
need to think about and but they're like
yeah they took that two hundred dollars
down i could it took three days took day
did he
harmony took the hold off of it that
sometimes does happen yeah but you don't
need to be doing stuff that you can't
afford
that that's the other thing so
yeah it's up to you kyle you get to
decide man but uh the trade-off for me
is obvious it's a minor irritation
versus the damage that credit cards have
done to american families for decades